- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première question
va être posée
par le groupe
Rassemblement National
par l'intermédiaire
de monsieur Roger Chudeau.
- Roger Chudeau:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la ministre
de l'Education nationale,
ma question porte
sur la carte scolaire
du premier degré.
Tout comme vos 15
glorieux prédécesseurs,
vous affirmez
que l'enseignement
des fondamentaux
reste la priorité.
Votre prédécesseur
le plus bref déclare
que l'éducation
est la mère
de toutes les politiques.
L'Association
des Maires de France,
des maires ruraux,
les départements font remonter
aux députés de vives
protestations
à ce sujet.
Il s'agit des départements
de la France périphérique,
France oubliée,
France méprisée
par l'oligarchie macronienne.
Dans le Loir-et-Cher,
24 suppressions,
après 17 l'an passé,
et le recteur annonce
que ce n'est pas fini.
Ne répondez pas que vous auriez
pu
en supprimer davantage au vu
de l'évolution démographique.
Le système éducatif
de notre pays s'enfonce
dans notre dans la médiocrité.
50% des élèves qui entrent
en sixième lisent péniblement
avec leurs doigts.
S'ils étaient en surnombre,
vous pourriez mettre davantage
de remplaçants,
mettre davantage
de qualité.
Les peu regrettés
Elisabeth Borne
et Pap Ndiaye
avaient promis
que la carte scolaire en milieu
rural serait établie
sur une durée
de trois années
et en étroite
concertation
avec les municipalités.
Que reste-t-il de cet engagement?
Rien, bien entendu.
L'école est en état d'urgence.
Nous vous demandons
de prononcer
un moratoire
sur ces fermetures et d'ouvrir
le chantier maintes
fois repoussé
de l'organisation
de l'école primaire
en milieu rural.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
mon cher collègue.
La parole est à la ministre
de l'Education nationale,
de la Jeunesse et des Sports.
Mesdames et messieurs,
je vous demande d'écouter
la ministre.
Un peu de silence, merci.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra:
Monsieur
le député Roger Chudeau,
pour l'école
de la République,
aucun territoire
ne doit être négligé ni oublié.
Nous avons aujourd'hui
en France
le maillage territorial
le plus fin
en termes de nombre
d'écoles et à l'échelle
de notre pays.
Et le système
d'allocation des moyens
est basé sur la prise en compte
de différents critères.
De volume d'effectifs,
les dynamiques démographiques,
l'indice de position sociale
des établissements
et l'indice d'éloignement.
Nous avons,
grâce à toute la politique
menée depuis 2017
sur l'éducation,
amélioré les ratios
d'encadrement
et baissé le nombre
d'écoliers par classe...
Le nombre d'élèves par classe
de manière extrêmement
significative.
J'insiste
puisque votre question porte
sur la ruralité,
sur la dynamique
que nous avons engagée
en la matière.
Les écoles rurales
représentent 34%
des écoles publiques
pour 18% des élèves.
Elles représentent un taux
d'encadrement favorable.
Les engagements
que vous avez mentionnés issus
du plan France
ruralités, je m'engage
à les mettre en oeuvre.
Oui, c'est sur trois ans
au niveau
de la carte scolaire.
Oui aussi,
des initiatives innovantes.
Je pense aux territoires
éducatifs ruraux.
Cet engagement,
je le respecterai
sous toutes ses dimensions.
Carte scolaire,
territoires éducatifs ruraux
et instances de coordination
et de dialogue
entre les élus
et les services de l'Etat
pour la réussite
de tous les élèves
de ce pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Antoine Armand
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Antoine Armand:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Economie,
des Finances
et de la Souveraineté
industrielle
et numérique.
Notre pays fait face
à un mur énergétique.
D'ici 2050 et même
d'ici 2030,
comme le président
de la République
l'a présenté à Belfort,
nous devrons baisser
comme jamais notre consommation
d'énergie et,
dans le même temps,
nous devrons produire
une quantité inédite
d'énergie bas carbone.
Sobriété, énergies
renouvelables
et nucléaire.
Il s'agit d'un défi immense.
Ce défi
ne souffrira pas le droit
à la paresse intellectuelle.
Il ne souffrira pas
les incohérences incorrigibles
et c'est une urgence écologique.
Ce défi
ne souffrira pas les postures
des patriotes du dimanche
qui défendent
la France,
nous disent-ils,
sauf quand il s'agit
d'installer
des énergies renouvelables
qui réduisent
la dépendance au gaz russe.
Ce mur, c'est le défi
industriel
de notre temps.
Nous nous réjouissons
que l'industrie retrouve...
Que l'énergie retrouve
le giron du ministère
de l'Industrie
comme nous l'avions recommandé
dans la commission
d'enquête à laquelle
j'ai participé.
Nous aurons besoin
de panneaux solaires,
d'éoliennes, de centrales
et d'infrastructures énergétiques
en Europe
pour que la transition
soit aussi
la réindustrialisation
que vous avez lancée,
monsieur le ministre,
que vous poursuivez
depuis 2017
contre vents et marées.
Aussi, pouvez-vous
préciser le calendrier
et les modalités
de la stratégie énergétique
que vous comptez
poursuivre
pour notre pays?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est au ministre
de l'Economie, des Finances
et de la Souveraineté
industrielle
et numérique.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Le défi français
est simple, c'est produire
plus d'électricité décarbonée
dans les années qui viennent.
Un défi considérable
parce que,
c'est le défi
de notre capacité
à le relever.
Ca dépend de notre capacité
à réindustrialiser
notre pays, à développer
de nouveaux secteurs économiques,
à développer l'industrie
automobile, l'industrie
aéronautique...
Il faut doubler la production
d'électricité décarbonée
en France.
Qu'est-ce que ça suppose?
D'abord, nous appuyer
sur nos atouts stratégiques.
Le premier,
ce sont les réacteurs nucléaires.
Nous avons engagé
la construction
de six nouveaux EPR avec première
livraison d'ici 2035.
D'autres pourraient
suivre si les besoins
étaient justifiés.
Deuxième chose,
accélérer le développement
des énergies renouvelables,
le solaire,
les offshore ou onshore,
et l'utilisation
des barrages qui devraient
être mieux utilisés.
Votre région le sait parfaitement.
Le troisième enjeu
a été rappelé
par le président
de la République
à Belfort,
c'est économiser l'énergie.
Faire preuve de davantage
de sobriété, d'efficacité.
Récupérer l'énergie
des secteurs industriels
pour pouvoir la réutiliser
sur le chauffage
d'un certain nombre de communes.
Avec cette stratégie
simple, claire
et lisible, volontariste,
plus d'électricité,
de nucléaire,
plus de sobriété,
plus d'efficacité,
la France occupera
la place qui lui revient,
la première économie décarbonée
d'Europe à horizon 2040.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Sabrina Sebaihi
pour le groupe Ecologistes.
- Sabrina Sebaihi:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
nous revenons de Rafah
à l'initiative
de notre collègue Eric Coquerel.
C'est le seul point d'entrée
de l'aide humanitaire
dans la bande de Gaza.
Nous avons vu des kilomètres
de camions interdits d'entrée
par Israël.
Une ambulance
par jour peut passer
pour plus de 2 millions
de Gazaouis n'ayant
plus accès aux soins.
Une ambulance par jour
pour l'unique hôpital
encore en service
de la bande de Gaza
où les personnels décrivent
des conditions effroyables.
Le médecin français Raphaël Pitti
n'avait jamais
vu de telles conditions,
de tels massacres
de civils dans un tel
conflit armé.
Alors que l'offensive
israélienne
a été décrite
comme représentant
un sérieux risque
génocidaire
par la Cour internationale
de justice, est-il
du devoir de la France
de poser fièrement
avec un dirigeant d'extrême
droite responsable
de plus de 27.000 morts
dont plus de 5000 enfants
en lui demandant
simplement le respect
des frontières de 67?
De ne pas condamner
l'offensive aveugle
et démesurée israélienne
qui a rasé 90%
des infrastructures
civiles
dans des territoires
les plus densément peuplés
au monde?
De remettre en cause
le financement
de l'agence
des Nations Unies, l'UNRWA,
seule capable de secourir
la population civile
dans l'enclave
alors que plusieurs
de nos pays voisins
comme l'Espagne
ou l'Irlande ont augmenté
leur soutien?
Le devoir
de la France
est d'être du côté
de la dignité,
des opprimés, de poursuivre
l'héritage international
chiraquien qui nous disait:
tant que les Palestiniens
ne devront pas s'accommoder
d'une existence
au rabais, les frustrations
et l'amertume l'emporteront.
Le devoir de la France,
c'est la demande
d'un cessez-le-feu.
Dans une enclave
où on tue à huis clos,
le devoir de la France,
c'est de refuser
toutes les colonisations.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à la porte-parole
du gouvernement.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Madame la députée,
je vous prie d'excuser le ministre
Stéphane Séjourné.
Les messages et les objectifs
des déplacements
du ministre
sont clairs: rappeler
les devoirs de la France.
Condamnation sans ambiguïté
des actes terroristes
du Hamas, demande
de libération de l'ensemble
des otages...
Un cessez-le-feu durable
pour que cesse l'enjeu humanitaire
sur place.
Consolider et accroître
l'aide médicale.
Politiquement,
notre objectif est constant:
oeuvrer vers une sortie
de crise
avec une solution
politique à deux Etats.
Nous avons participé à l'envoi
de 1000 tonnes d'aide
vers la bande de Gaza.
La France s'engage
à continuer et continuera
à s'engager
pour un cessez-le-feu
sans délai.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
madame la ministre.
La parole, pour le groupe
La France Insoumise
est à monsieur Eric Coquerel.
- Eric Coquerel:
Monsieur le ministre,
nous nous sommes rendus
à Rafah
avec plusieurs parlementaires.
Nous avons porté
un message de paix.
Le cessez-le-feu
immédiat assorti
de la libération des otages
est nécessaire.
Nous avons rencontré les médecins
humanitaires français.
Je vais donner
la voix à l'un d'eux.
Il décrit leur hôpital,
le seul
à peu près intact
comme un chaos sanitaire
où un tiers des patients
sont des victimes
des bombardements
et des snipers israéliens.
Il n'a vu
parmi eux que des civils.
Il le certifie.
Une minorité capable à peine
de se traîner jusqu'à eux.
Les autres meurent dans la rue.
Le reste des pathologies
deviennent mortelles.
Il a été médecin
militaire en Ukraine.
Il n'a jamais vu pareil désastre.
Il dit aussi:
"Il y a pire que tuer
un homme, c'est lui enlever
sa dignité."
Dans un mois,
l'interrogation
sur le génocide
ne sera plus en cours
car l'UNRWA pourrait
s'arrêter faute
de financement.
Monsieur le ministre,
votre position
pour un cessez-le-feu
a été appréciée
en Egypte et par les représentants
palestiniens
mais sur c'est une question
vitale,
la France doit faire plus.
La France
n'a pas suspendu son aide
mais pouvez-vous affirmer
qu'elle poursuivra
les versements
au moins jusqu'au rendu
du groupe d'évaluation
de sa neutralité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la porte-parole
du gouvernement,
madame Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Monsieur le député Coquerel,
je ne vais pas reprendre
tous les éléments
que j'ai fournis
à votre collègue précédemment.
Je vous transmets
la réponse du ministre
des Affaires
étrangères
qui est encore en tournée
diplomatique
dans la zone.
La France poursuit
son soutien à l'agence
des Nations Unies,
qui ne prévoyait
aucun versement au premier
trimestre 2024.
La rédaction du rapport
a été confiée
à Catherine Colonna
par le secrétaire
des Nations Unies.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Victor Castor
pour le groupe Gauche Démocrate
et Républicaine.
- Jean-Victor Castor:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le ministre,
ma question s'adresse
au Premier ministre.
Respecterez-vous
le vote unanime
des élus de Guyane
du 26 mars 2022
pour avoir un article
propre
dans la Constitution,
comme vous l'avez confirmé?
Le congrès
des élus réunit
tous les maires,
tous les élus territoriaux,
les parlementaires
et tous les présidents.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est au ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
comme vous l'avez vous-même dit,
la Guyane qui réfléchit
à son avenir institutionnel...
Je sais que le président
de la collectivité
ainsi que les élus
ont déjà évoqué auprès
du président de la République
réfléchir là-dessus.
Vous savez
que le président
de la République
a ouvert cette voie,
indépendamment
de la question calédonienne
sur les territoires
ultramarins,
et a accompagné
la question pas seulement
par les élus.
Nous avons pris
acte des votes
de la collectivité
territoriale
mais également de la population.
Il nous faut
connaître la façon
dont le conseil
territorial va consulter
les électeurs guyanais.
Nous avons vu dans d'autres
territoires ultramarins
des volontés
par les élus
qui n'étaient pas toujours
suivies
par les habitants,
les populations intéressées,
ni la constitution.
Le président de la République aura
bientôt l'occasion
de se rendre
dans la belle terre
de Guyane.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Castor?
- Jean-Victor Castor:
Le 21 avril 2017,
plus de 21.000 personnes
étaient dans les rues
de Guyane.
Les accords ont entériné
l'ouverture
d'un nouveau processus
d'évolution statutaire.
Le 17 octobre,
vous avez vous-même initié
la rencontre avec la Guyane
sur un processus
de discussion
similaire à celui
de la Corse qui devait aboutir
en septembre 2023.
Malgré toutes les relances,
le gouvernement
est resté sourd
durant plus d'un an.
La nomination
de deux experts aujourd'hui
est de l'enfumage
qui consiste à ignorer
un processus engagé
depuis le Premier ministre Edouard
Philippe.
La Guyane
est un territoire
avec de grandes ressources,
il est inadmissible
que 53%
de la population vive
sous le seuil de pauvreté.
La situation
chaotique guyanaise
a pour conséquence
l'empilement de normes
et de décisions politiques
parisiennes inadaptées
et absurdes.
Est-ce normal
que le commerce
avec nos voisins
immédiats soit entravé
à l'heure de la sobriété
énergétique?
Que des agriculteurs renoncent
à s'installer faute
de terres exploitables
sur un territoire aussi vaste?
Le statu quo n'est plus possible.
Il est évident
que la Guyane doit changer
de statut.
Elle en a toutes les ressources.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin:
Je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas écouté
la réponse
que je viens
de vous faire en disant
que nous étions favorables
à l'évolution statutaire.
Vous ne vous êtes pas
engagé
sur la consultation
de la population guyanaise.
Comme en Corse
et en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
il faut consulter les habitants.
Les manifestations
ne font pas les élections.
Dans le projet porté
par les collectivités,
vous voulez
une citoyenneté guyanaise
et un corps électoral citoyen.
Je pense que ça laisse
le soin aux Guyanais
de voter pour leur avenir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La prochaine question
va être posée
par monsieur
Frédéric Zgainski
pour le groupe Démocrates.
- Frédéric Zgainski:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
mes chers collègues,
je m'adresse
à monsieur Marc
Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté alimentaire.
Vous avez pris
une décision difficile
mais nécessaire
concernant la suspension
du plan Ecophyto.
Il est impératif d'accompagner
nos agriculteurs
dans cette voie
de la suppression
de certains produits.
Cela nécessite un vrai
soutien à l'innovation
pour trouver des alternatives
aux produits
de synthèse.
Je pense aux solutions
de biocontrôle
qui font appel
à des mécanismes naturels.
Ces alternatives
aux pesticides
sont efficaces
et respectueuses
de la santé des sols,
des écosystèmes
et des populations.
Il est urgent de soutenir
cette filière.
10 millions d'euros
par an sont prévus
pour des projets
de recherche
et de déploiement.
Il faut amplifier
cet effort
pour que les
expérimentations
et la recherche accélèrent.
Il est nécessaire d'accélérer
les processus d'homologation
longs, complexes
et décourageants
pour nos jeunes
entreprises françaises.
Nous avons des entreprises
françaises leaders
dans ces domaines.
Il faut les soutenir
pour conserver
notre avance et travailler
à la reconquête
de notre souveraineté alimentaire.
Pouvez-vous
nous dire
quels sont les leviers
que le gouvernement compte activer
pour favoriser le développement
de solutions alternatives,
françaises, et accompagner
les agriculteurs
vers la transition
écologique
tout en maintenant compétitivité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est au ministre
de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté alimentaire.
- Marc Fesneau:
Monsieur le député,
deux éléments de réponse.
Sur le plan Ecophyto,
nous l'avons mis
en pause
pour quelques semaines
le temps d'analyser des choses.
D'une part, les indicateurs.
Il nous en faut
un qui ne soit pas
un processus de découragement.
Et il nous faut des mesures
de simplification
pour éviter les surtranspositions.
Je pense au registre numérique.
S'inspirant
des travaux menés
par des députés,
il faut se demander pourquoi
Ecophyto
ne va pas aussi loin
qu'on l'avait pensé en 2009.
Deuxièmement, les alternatives.
Il y en a différents types.
L'innovation doit pouvoir
s'accompagner d'une rapidité
sur les homologations.
Une innovation doit
pouvoir plus rapidement
se déployer.
Il faut travailler
au niveau national
et au niveau européen pour qu'une
alternative puisse
être mise rapidement
à disposition
des agriculteurs.
Cette innovation
doit aller
dans les cours de fermes.
Ensuite, il y a les moyens
à y consacrer.
Nous organiserons
avec Sylvie Retailleau
un programme pour encourager
les biostimulants
et les outils du biocontrôle.
Nous avons besoin
que les firmes puissent entrer
dans la logique
pour accompagner
les solutions dont ont besoin
les agriculteurs.
La transition, ça doit
être des moyens,
les objectifs
et de l'accompagnement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Fabrice Brun
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Fabrice Brun: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, les tracteurs
sont tout juste rentrés
dans leurs fermes
que les déclarations
contradictoires
des membres
du gouvernement fusent
dans le désordre.
Si vous pensez avoir berné
les agriculteurs
ou avoir acheté
leur silence, vous faites
une grave erreur.
Sans traduction
de vos paroles en actes d'ici
le salon de l'agriculture,
le retour
de manivelle sera terrible.
Terrible
pour notre agriculture
et notre alimentation,
pour notre économie
qui ne résisterait pas
à l'agglomération
de toutes les colères
après 7 ans
de fracturation macroniste.
Les agriculteurs
veulent vivre dignement
de leur métier,
plus de rémunération,
moins de charges,
moins de normes
avec un cap clair:
pas d'interdiction
sans solution.
Arrêtez d'emmerder
les agriculteurs
et les éleveurs français!
Contrôlez plutôt les rayons
et les containers.
On n'en peut
plus de cette concurrence
déloyale
des produits
qui ne respectent pas les mêmes
normes
que nous.
Choc de simplification,
réparation
de la caisse des retraites
agricoles, prédation,
GNR, Ecophyto, application
de la loi Egalim,
les solutions existent.
C'est une question
de volonté politique.
Comme l'eau qu'il faut
stocker partout
où c'est possible
et pas au cas
par cas,
selon le bon vouloir
de votre administration.
C'est du bon sens paysan.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, serez-vous
au rendez-vous
des promesses tenues
au Salon de l'agriculteur?
Vous êtes attendus au tournant!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est au ministre de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Monsieur le député,
vous avez fait
la liste des sujets
que nous avons mis
nous-mêmes
sur la table.
Ne croyez pas
que nous considérions
que la crise est finie.
Des réponses
ont été apportées
dans l'immédiateté
pour répondre
aux crises bovines et viticoles.
Les agriculteurs
nous attendent
dans la durée,
avant le salon,
et ils attendent après le salon.
20 ou 30 ans
de difficultés posées
sur la table,
il faut faire
ce que nous pouvons
et s'inscrire
dans la durée.
Dans le temps
qui nous amène au salon,
nous allons travailler
sur les mesures
de simplification.
Des mesures
ont été indiquées
par le Premier ministre
sur les délais
de recours,
sur les procédures
qui sont trop lourdes
et nous travaillons
avec les organisations
professionnelles départementales
sous l'égide des préfets
pour regarder
tout le champ
de simplification
que nous devons ouvrir.
La sédimentation
reste très grande.
On va avancer aussi
sur les autres sujets.
Je pense au sujet européen.
J'ai entendu ce que la présidente
Ursula von der Leyen
a dit.
Il faut que la politique
agricole permette
à la fois la transition
mais aussi s'assurer
de la souveraineté agricole.
Nous devons travailler là-dessus.
Nous avons des mesures
de court terme.
Le projet de loi
agricole sera présenté
avec un calendrier
qui permettra d'ici
le mois de juin
que les deux lectures puissent
être faites
à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat.
Je suis sûr
que vous apporterez
votre contribution
pour engager la transition
et la volonté
de souveraineté
que nous partageons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Arthur Delaporte
pour le groupe Socialistes.
- Arthur Delaporte:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
vous aviez promis
d'apporter la cause
de l'école à Matignon.
Mais de quelle école parlez-vous?
Celle de l'école publique,
gratuite, laïque
et obligatoire ou celle
de l'école payante,
réservée à une caste
et aux beaux quartiers?
Celle de la mixité
sociale
ou celle de la ségrégation
scolaire?
Celle de la laïcité
qui s'impose
ou celle des cours
religieux imposés?
Celle de l'égalité
entre les sexes
ou celle des classes
pour les filles
et des classes pour les garçons?
Celle de l'éducation civique
et de l'éducation
à la vie sexuelle
ou celle qui prône
des discours sexistes
et homophobes?
Celle de l'émancipation
des élèves
ou celle de l'uniforme
obligatoire?
Celle de l'éducation
populaire
ou celle du Service
national universel
et d'endoctrinement
de la jeunesse?
Celle du libre choix
de son orientation
ou celle de Parcoursup contourné?
Celle
d'un enseignant
devant chaque classe
ou celle dans laquelle
on supprime 6500
postes depuis 2017?
La colère gronde.
Dans le Finistère,
en Isère,
dans le Puy-de-Dôme
ou le Calvados,
des écoles ferment.
Partout en France,
les revendications
sont les mêmes.
Des dizaines de milliers
d'enseignants
sont dans la rue
et scandent
dans la rue:
"Amélie Oudéa-Castéra,
démission!"
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, écoutez-les,
pour une fois.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra,
ministre de l'Education
nationale,
de la Jeunesse et des Sports.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra:
Monsieur
le député, opposer
l'école publique
à l'école privée,
c'est une guerre
d'un autre âge.
Il est hors de question
de la raviver.
Depuis la loi Debré de 59,
les unes cohabitent
avec les autres.
Liberté de l'enseignement
et qualité
du service public, de l'éducation.
50% des familles
ont fait le choix
à un moment
ou à un autre de mettre
un de leurs enfants
dans une école privée.
Je vais exprimer
notre volonté illustrée
par la mobilisation de 60.000
effectifs supplémentaires
pour nous assurer
que l'école privée
est au rendez-vous
de ses obligations
en matière pédagogique,
financière
et administrative
sur le plan du respect
des valeurs
de la République
et tout particulièrement
de la laïcité.
Mais aussi en matière
de mixité sociale
et scolaire.
Le secrétariat national
de l'enseignement catholique
a pris
des engagements
dont nous nous assurons
de la bonne mise
en oeuvre.
Meilleur suivi
dans les conditions d'accès
aux enseignements privés,
plus de transparence
sur les conditions d'accès.
Donc une amélioration
du taux de boursiers.
Nous voulons nous assurer
de l'effective mise
en oeuvre de tous
ces dispositifs-là.
Ce protocole assorti
de moyens spécifiques,
nous ferons en sorte
qu'il y ait
le bon niveau d'exigence.
L'école privée
mérite des moyens,
ni plus ni moins que la juste
allocation
avec une prise
en compte de l'indice
de position sociale
des établissements
pour faire réussir
tous les élèves
de notre pays
et toutes les écoles
de notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Arthur Delaporte:
La guerre scolaire,
c'est vous qui la ravivez.
C'est vous qui employez
ces termes.
C'est vous qui refusez
de démissionner
et qui n'assumez pas.
Vous insultez les enseignants.
C'est votre bilan
et celui
de votre gouvernement.
Ecoutez les enseignants!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Guy Bricout
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Guy Bricout:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Les maires me font
part de beaucoup
de difficultés
à gérer leur commune
mais dans presque
toutes les communes,
j'ai entendu les maires
vouloir rénover
ou construire une école.
Nous venons d'apprendre
la fermeture
de nombreuses classes
dans le pays.
29 dans ma circonscription,
l'année dernière.
Réduire à une seule
classe une école
dans un village,
c'est condamner l'école.
L'école est un lien
indéfectible
de la nation avec ses enfants.
Notre classement
au niveau mondial
ne fait que dégringoler.
Nous ne pouvons nier
une décrue démographique
mais elle existe depuis 2017.
Les classes ont été
pourtant maintenues
grâce à des
"dispositifs",
c'est le terme employé.
Pourquoi fermer
drastiquement les classes
en 2022?
Nous estimons
que cette situation doit
être l'opportunité de diminuer
le nombre d'élèves
par classe, d'autant
plus que les dédoublements
et le plafonnement
des classes
ont fait leurs preuves.
Votre choix a-t-il
été de supprimer
des postes dans le premier
et le second degrés,
un choix auquel
nous nous sommes opposés
avec le groupe LIOT
lors de l'amendement
des deux derniers
budgets,
avant que ne tombe le 49.3.
Vous voudriez
une concertation
qui ne fera qu'appliquer
les recommandations
du ministre.
Vous avez l'occasion
de répondre
à un réel enjeu
pour l'avenir
de nos territoires.
Comment allez-vous
mettre en place
une politique
publique efficace
contre les fermetures
de classes
en général et quelles réponses
pouvez-vous apporter
aux parents
et enfants touchés
par de nombreuses fermetures?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à la ministre
de l'Education nationale,
de la Jeunesse et des sports.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra:
Merci
pour votre question,
monsieur le député,
qui est extraordinairement
importante,
avoir une carte
scolaire qui prenne
en compte les indices
d'éloignement
et de position sociale
des établissements,
l'évolution des effectifs
et les dynamiques démographiques,
nos équipes y veillent
sur le terrain.
Je veux revenir
sur l'évolution
des taux d'encadrement.
Compte tenu
de la politique
que nous avons menée
en matière de dédoublement
des classes
dans le primaire,
les ratios se sont améliorés.
Je veux vous donner
ces explications
pour la ruralité.
Les taux d'encadrement
en milieu rural
sont très favorables
avec une moyenne
de 19,4 élèves par classe
dans les communes rurales
éloignées.
Une amélioration
par rapport à 2020.
Simplement, nous sommes à certains
moments obligés
de procéder
à certaines fermetures
de classes.
Des écoles peuvent
être performantes
mais si le nombre
d'enfants
est trop réduit
pour une classe donnée,
l'émulation et la capacité
de progression
de nos enfants
sont remises en cause.
Nous portons
une égale ambition
pour tous les territoires
dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire mais aussi
pour la ruralité
où il y a cette
concertation
que vous avez évoquée.
Il y a la mise en place
des territoires éducatifs ruraux,
190 à la rentrée
prochaine,
qui nous permet
de travailler
avec tous les services
de l'Etat,
toutes les associations
et les élus
pour proposer des solutions
adaptées, innovantes
et constructives
pour les élèves
dans la ruralité.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à présent
à monsieur Thierry Benoit
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Thierry Benoit:
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie, la mobilisation
des agriculteurs
a continué de poser la question
du revenu agricole,
notamment pour les éleveurs.
Le gouvernement
a pointé le rôle
de centrales d'achat
internationales hébergées
à l'étranger, permettant
à certaines négociations
commerciales d'échapper
au droit français.
Quelles sont les mesures
que l'Union Européenne peut mettre
en oeuvre pour que la loi
Egalim s'applique
à la lettre en France,
mais aussi
en Europe?
Dans le secteur laitier,
les organisations
de producteurs
sont en grande difficulté
dans la contractualisation
avec certains industriels.
C'est le cas
avec l'entreprise Lactalis,
par exemple.
Il y a aussi la crainte
pour certains éleveurs laitiers
de ne plus être collectés
au 8 mars.
Les pouvoirs publics
sont aujourd'hui interpellés
par les organisations
de producteurs.
Quelles suites le gouvernement
entend-il donner
à l'alerte de certaines
organisations
de producteurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est au ministre
de l'Economie
et des Finances.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Monsieur le député,
vous pouvez compter
sur la détermination totale
du gouvernement,
du Premier ministre,
du ministre de l'Agriculture
et de moi-même
à faire respecter
les dispositions
de la loi EGalim.
Un produit négocié et vendu
en France respecte
toutes les dispositions
de la loi EGalim.
J'ai demandé à ce que tous
les produits négociés
par l'intermédiaire européennes
respectent rigoureusement
l'ensemble des dispositions
de la loi EGalim.
Sur 1000 contrats,
nous en avons 124
qui ne respectent pas
les dispositions
de la loi EGalim.
J'ai envoyé des injonctions
aux 124 industriels
et distributeurs concernés.
Ils ont 15 jours
pour se conformer
à la loi, faute
de quoi ils encourent
une sanction de 5
millions d'euros
par distributeurs
aux groupes industriels.
Nous avons créé nous-mêmes,
quand j'étais ministre
de l'Agriculture
et vous député
des organisations
de producteurs,
des aides
pour les industriels
et les distributeurs.
Il n'est pas acceptable
que des industriels puissent
négocier le prix
de leurs produits
avec les distributeurs
alors qu'ils n'ont
pas conclu
leurs négociations
avec les producteurs de lait.
Nous veillerons
à ce que la loi EGalim
soit renforcée.
- Thierry Benoit:
Il me reste
quelque secondes.
Sur les centrales
d'achat hébergées
dans d'autres pays que la France,
l'Union Européenne devrait
procéder au même
travail
que nous avons fait ici:
une commission d'enquête
sur le fonctionnement
des centrales d'achat hébergées
à l'international
et notamment en Europe.
Sur les organisations
de producteurs,
l'objectif
que vous aviez fixé
quand vous étiez ministre
de l'Agriculture,
c'était la contractualisation.
Les industriels doivent
donner l'exemple
dans le domaine
du prix de façon
à ce que l'ensemble
des industriels
et des éleveurs laitiers
soient rémunérés
à la hauteur des efforts
qu'ils fournissent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Philippe Schreck
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Philippe Schreck:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Je vous rappelle
les chiffres
que vous connaissez
car ils ont été communiqués
par votre ministère
la semaine dernière.
En 2023, les coups
et blessures volontaires
ont progressé de 7%.
Les violences
intrafamiliales, de 9%.
Les viols et tentatives, de 10%.
Les cambriolages
et dégradations volontaires,
de 3%.
Des hommes et des femmes
broyés se trouvent
derrière ces chiffres.
Plus que des statistiques,
vos chiffres
sont des marqueurs du deuil,
de la souffrance
et de la peur.
La hausse
de la délinquance violente
est constante et touche tous
les territoires.
Ceux qui considèrent
que la France
n'est pas
un coupe-gorge
ne voient pas la réalité
que vivent
les Français.
Monsieur le ministre,
avez-vous conscience
que la sécurité
n'est pas un sentiment?
Comment allez-vous
casser la courbe
de la délinquance?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Monsieur le député,
je partage, bien
votre avis selon lequel
la sécurité
n'est pas un sentiment,
mais il faut
lutter
contre avec toute son énergie.
Je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas eu
un mot pour les policiers
et les gendarmes
qui se mettent tous les jours...
Sans doute
que ça ne vous arrange pas...
Vous ne souhaitez
sans doute pas
les soutenir.
Je veux dire
que je suis fier
d'être à leur tête
depuis bientôt
quatre ans car je sais
qu'ils font
un travail quotidien...
Dans votre département,
monsieur
le député,
dommage
que vous n'ayez pas cette vision
locale
des chiffres
de la délinquance
de vos policiers.
Vous verriez
qu'il y en a 143
en plus dans
votre département
et que dans le Var,
c'est -28% de vols
de véhicules, -6%
de vols avec armes,
-11% de vols violents.
Ce qui vous intéresse,
ce sont les choses négatives.
Il faut évidemment les combattre.
Vous n'avez pas cité
l'intégralité
des chiffres.
-10% de violences
dans les transports,
-8% de vols violents.
La vérité,
c'est que vous êtes heureux
quand les Français
vont mal, monsieur
le député.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Philippe Schreck:
Manifestement,
votre gouvernement
continue
à avoir quelques
difficultés
avec les mathématiques.
Un ancien ministre
de l'Agriculture n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'un
hectare représentait.
Vous nous expliquez
que plus et plus font moins.
Si les homicides
volontaires ont progressé
depuis que vous
êtes au pouvoir,
ce n'est pas
qu'il y a moins de morts,
c'est qu'il y en a
plus chaque année.
Vous n'êtes pas le ministre
du Var,
mais de l'ensemble du pays.
Les Français,
chaque semaine,
sont victimes
de la politique désastreuse
que vous menez.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Monsieur le député,
vos électeurs du Var seront
ravis d'apprendre
que vous vous fichez
de votre département.
C'est l'inconvénient
d'écrire
votre réponse avant d'entendre
ma réponse,
vous utilisez les éléments
de monsieur Bardella
au lieu de vous occuper
des Français!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Michel Lauzzana
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Michel Lauzzana:
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté alimentaire.
Dans ma circonscription,
à Agen,
j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'échanger
avec des agriculteurs,
des femmes
et des hommes portant
des revendications légitimes
et voulant faire
entendre leur mal-être
et leurs difficultés pesant
sur la profession
depuis plusieurs décennies.
Accablés par des normes
et des injonctions souvent
contradictoires,
ils consacrent
leur vie et celle
de leur famille
à leur métier sans pouvoir
s'en sortir dignement.
Pourtant,
ils ne perdent pas l'espoir
de vivre correctement
de leur travail citoyen.
Les revendications sont multiples.
Les besoins
sont parfois différents
selon les régions
et les secteurs
de production.
Je salue l'éventail
très concret
et adapté de vos annonces
qui ont permis d'apporter
des réponses rapides et claires.
Il y aura
un avant et un après cette
mobilisation avec, par exemple,
le grand chantier
de simplification,
que nous devrons dupliquer
à tous les secteurs
de l'action publique.
Cette nouvelle démarche
est nécessaire.
Les agriculteurs
restent attentifs
aux résultats concrets.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer
quelles mesures concrètes
vous avez déjà
prises
et quels sont les dossiers
sur lesquels
vous travaillez d'ici au salon
de l'agriculture
pour répondre aux besoins
des agriculteurs
et soutenir
notre modèle agricole
et notre modèle français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est au ministre
de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté alimentaire.
- Marc Fesneau:
Monsieur le député,
merci de votre question.
Les agriculteurs
ont posé sur la table
une question existentielle:
la capacité
à pouvoir vivre de leur travail.
Le deuxième sujet
est leur rapport
à la société.
Parfois, les discours
de la stigmatisation
leur ont fait beaucoup de mal.
Nous avons répondu
dans l'urgence
avec le Premier ministre
et les autres collègues ministres
sur plusieurs sujets.
Je pense d'abord
au secteur des bovins,
de la viticulture, du bio...
Des fonds d'urgence déployés
pour certains d'entre
eux vont permettre
de soulager les trésoreries
et de faire face
aux situations
les plus périlleuses.
Sur les bovins,
la question de la réponse
à la MHE, c'est un défi
pour cette filière.
Nous avons besoin aussi
sur la question viticole
de travailler sur les questions
structurelles.
Un travail
que nous avons commencé
il y a plusieurs
mois pour faire
en sorte que nous répondions
à la demande.
Nous avons travaillé
avec mon collègue Christophe Béchu
pour voir
ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour accélérer les processus,
les simplifier
et les rendre
plus lisibles
pour les agriculteurs.
Nous avons du travail
devant nous:
la simplification
de la transition
et la compétitivité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Marianne Maximi
pour le groupe
de La France Insoumise.
- Marianne Maximi: Merci.
C'était une enfant.
Elle avait 15 ans.
La semaine dernière,
elle s'est donné
la mort dans sa chambre
d'hôtel,
où elle a été placée
par l'Aide sociale
à l'enfance.
Je voudrais
que notre Assemblée
lui rende hommage
et apporte son soutien
à ses proches,
aux éducateurs,
qui font du mieux qu'ils peuvent.
Le contexte est désastreux.
Madame la ministre,
que faisait
une enfant de 15 ans
seule dans un hôtel?
Ne me répondez pas que c'était
un hôtel.
Les hôtels restent des hôtels.
L'Etat connaissait
la dangerosité
de ce type de placement.
Beaucoup d'enfants
sont morts
dans ce type d'hébergement.
En 2019, l'Inspection générale
des affaires sociales
a alerté sur les dangers
bien identifiés,
dont l'isolement
et l'exposition
au trafic et à la prostitution.
En 2022,
les placements en hôtels
ont été interdits.
Que s'est-il passé depuis?
Rien!
Le décret d'application
n'est jamais paru.
Une dizaine d'autres non plus.
La loi de 2022
est l'une des lois
les moins appliquées
de tout le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Cela dit beaucoup
du mépris social
qui entoure le devenir
des enfants placés.
Pourtant, ces enfants
ont des droits.
L'Etat a envers eux des devoirs.
Qui va réparer
la protection de l'enfance
que le gouvernement
laisse s'effondrer?
Qui va réparer
les familles
qui n'ont pas trouvé
d'aide
dont elles avaient besoin?
Qui va réparer
les enfants brisés
par des parcours
chaotiques à la protection
de l'enfance?
Qui va réparer
des professionnels
en souffrance?
Il nous faut commencer
dès maintenant
à prendre des mesures fortes.
Quand comptez-vous
interdire les placements
en hôtels?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Au nom du gouvernement,
permettez-moi,
à mon tour, d'apporter
tout mon soutien
aux proches de cette enfant,
mais également
aux professionnels
touchés
par cette disparition tragique.
Une cellule
psychologique a été mise
en place pour apporter
tout le soutien nécessaire
à l'équipe éducative ainsi
qu'aux autres jeunes
de l'établissement.
Une enquête est en cours
et va permettre
de faire toute la lumière
sur ce drame absolu.
La loi Taquet
du 7 février 2022
qui avait suite à un travail
approfondi plusieurs mois
avec tous les professionnels
concernés
et les départements
de France a permis
que la parole de l'enfant
soit davantage prise
en compte et mieux
prise en compte.
Un certain nombre
de décrets d'application
ont déjà été publiés,
mais d'autres
étaient en attente.
Le gouvernement
souhaite poursuivre
le dialogue
avec les départements
sur les conditions
de mise en oeuvre
de cette loi.
Nous le devons
à tous ces enfants
qui n'aspirent
qu'à vivre
comme tous les autres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Meyer Habib.
- Meyer Habib: Merci.
Quatre mois après les pogroms
du 7 octobre,
la France organise demain
un hommage national
à ces 42 enfants massacrés
par les djihadistes
du Hamas.
42 Français
massacrés et tués
devant leur famille.
Leurs corps ont été
profanés, exhibés
comme des trophées.
Je regrette que les familles
des dizaines
de soldats
franco-israéliens
ne soient pas conviés
à cet hommage.
Je pense aux 136
otages détenus
en ce moment dans les geôles
djihadistes.
Je pense
à toutes ces femmes violées
en permanence.
Après la compassion
et la sidération vient
le temps des accusations.
L'Afrique du Sud,
régime corrompu
et criminogène,
place l'Etat juif
sur le banc des accusés.
Le monde doit
comprendre que 80 ans
après la Shoah,
le peuple juif n'ira
plus jamais à l'abattoir
sans réagir.
Cette guerre a été
imposée à Israël.
C'est un acte de justice
et non de vengeance.
Pendant ce temps,
il n'y a pas eu
un mot pour les otages.
Comble de l'indécence,
les responsables
de tout cela seront là demain.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
je suis le député
de ces familles
qui ont écrit au président
de la République.
La France ne peut
balayer leur émotion
et leur colère.
De grâce, il faut
un sursaut d'humanité
envers les victimes.
Pourquoi ne pas dresser
un cordon sanitaire
avec les antisémites
qui font l'apologie
du terrorisme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Permettez-moi
de vous répondre au nom
du gouvernement.
Il y a quatre mois,
le 7 octobre 2023,
des vies ont été
violemment arrachées
par la folie terroriste.
Le 7 octobre 2023,
l'horreur surgissait
à nouveau dans le quotidien
des Israéliens.
Alors commençait
l'inéluctable souffrance
des familles des blessés.
Le 7 octobre 2023,
une attaque terroriste
des plus barbares
a été menée
par le Hamas
contre l'Etat d'Israël.
Par-delà nos divergences
politiques,
il y a des moments
qui nous appellent collectivement
à être à la hauteur.
L'hommage voulu
par le président
de la République
fait partie
de ces moments.
Demain, nous devons
nous souvenir ensemble
des noms et des visages
de celles
et ceux qui ont été
arrachés
à leur famille.
Si le protocole
prévoit d'inviter
tous les responsables politiques,
chacun appréciera l'opportunité
ou non de sa présence,
puisque les familles
se sont exprimées.
Je tiens une nouvelle
fois à dire
que justifier le terrorisme,
c'est accepter
qu'il frappe à nouveau.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Lionel Tivoli.
- Lionel Tivoli: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à Bruno Le Maire.
Après l'augmentation
du tarif du gaz
en janvier, qui fait
suite à la fin
du bouclier tarifaire,
une nouvelle augmentation
à compter du 1er juillet,
voilà le terrible cadeau
d'anniversaire
que vous offrez aux Français
pour célébrer la fin
des tarifs réglementés.
C'est donc
ce nouveau cadeau
que vous offrez
aux Français
quelques jours
seulement
après leur avoir offert
une augmentation
de 10% sur les tarifs
de l'électricité.
Plus incroyable,
une ex-ministre
de vos rangs justifie
que cette augmentation serait
bénéfique
pour le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages.
Sérieusement,
de qui vous moquez-vous?
C'est à l'exploitant
d'assumer le risque
et non pas aux consommateurs.
Aucun Français
ne se réjouira
de cette nouvelle ponction.
Votre soumission
aux instances européennes
est la seule responsable
de l'explosion
du prix du gaz.
Le marché subit
un alourdissement
des importations françaises
et la dégradation
de cette dépendance
envers cette énergie,
qui nous place sous la tutelle
de puissances étrangères.
Les Français sont à bout
de ces augmentations successives.
Le marché européen
de l'énergie
est un boulet
dans le pouvoir d'achat
de nos ménages.
Quand allez-vous
rompre avec les règles
de ce marché pour fixer
le prix du gaz?
Quand allez-vous
défendre les moyens
des Français?
Quand allez-vous
concéder à baisser
la TVA à 5,5 sur les énergies?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
C'est surtout
votre soumission
à Vladimir Poutine
qui a fait exploser
les prix du gaz.
C'est surtout votre soumission
aux intérêts étrangers
de la Russie
qui a fait exploser
les prix du gaz.
Les faits sont têtus.
Le prix du gaz
était à 80 euros
et a bondi à 200 euros
lors de l'intervention
de Vladimir Poutine,
que vous avez soutenue,
contre l'Ukraine!
Vous avez systématiquement
pris le parti
de l'étranger,
de la Russie
et de Vladimir Poutine
contre les intérêts
de la nation française.
Nous avons protégé
les consommateurs.
Vous avez défendu
vos amis de l'étranger.
Quant à la protection
du consommateur,
vous me posez
pour la énième fois
la même question.
Je vous apporterai donc
la même réponse.
Là où vous avez proposé
une baisse
de la TVA,
nous avons mis en place
un bouclier
sur l'électricité
et sur le gaz
qui a pris en charge
la moitié de la facture
du consommateur.
Vous êtes du côté
de l'étranger
contre la nation,
du côté du producteur
contre le consommateur.
Voilà la règle
du Rassemblement National!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Lionel Tivoli:
Excusez-moi,
mais le champion
de l'importation
du GNR russe,
c'est vous et votre gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Stéphane Buchou.
- Stéphane Buchou: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
Aujourd'hui,
cela fait 16 jours
que les pêcheurs
du golfe de Gascogne
sont à quai.
Ce sont plus de 450
bateaux
qui sont concernés
par l'interdiction
de pêche pendant un mois.
Cette fermeture
est vécue à la fois
comme une sanction
et comme une injustice.
S'il y a une profession
qui s'est adaptée
et qui a su se réadapter,
c'est la pêche.
Installation de caméras
embarquées, coopération
avec les scientifiques...
Une injustice,
parce qu'il s'agit
de captures
accidentelles
et que pas un pêcheur
ne part en mer
avec la volonté de tuer
des petits cétacés.
Après la baisse
de quota décidée
en fin d'année dernière,
c'est un nouveau coup
de massue.
Je veux saluer
l'accompagnement de l'Etat
et les aides annoncées
par le gouvernement,
mais dans les ports,
le sentiment
de résignation prédomine.
Les pêcheurs veulent
vivre de leur métier,
pas des aides.
Il faut proposer
des solutions qui permettent
que pêcheurs
et cétacés cohabitent.
Comment comptez-vous
répondre
à ces exigences?
Nous le devons à nos pêcheurs.
La pêche, c'est à la fois
notre histoire,
nos paysages et le poumon
de nos économies locales.
Un emploi en mer
génère
trois à quatre emplois sur terre.
Pendant ce mois de fermeture,
certains pêcheurs
vont perdre 600.000 euros
de chiffre d'affaires.
Vous avez rencontré
le comité national
des pêches la semaine dernière.
Que leur avez-vous
dit
et quelles sont
les perspectives
pour que la pêche
française
et toute la filière
puissent toujours
se conjuguer au futur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Oui, la pêche participe
à notre souveraineté alimentaire.
Insuffisamment,
puisque 70% du poisson
que nous consommons
en France est importé.
Je sais à la fois
la réalité des difficultés
des pêcheurs
et le soutien constant
que le gouvernement
leur a apporté
à travers les crises
qu'ils ont traversées.
Le Covid
a particulièrement impacté
la pêche française.
Le 22 décembre dernier,
le Conseil d'Etat
a considéré que le dispositif
de préservation
et de lutte contre les captures
accidentelles
était insuffisant.
Nous avons vécu
l'année dernière
avec près de 2500
captures accidentelles.
Des projections
qui menacent la survie
de l'espèce des dauphins
et des marsouins communs.
Avec 2500 prises,
c'est entre 5000
et 10.000 dauphins
qui sont menacés,
au-delà des taux
qui sont acceptables.
Pour autant, la fermeture
spatio-temporelle
de tous
les bateaux
de plus de huit mètres
est aussi importante.
Cela ne peut pas ne pas
être massivement accompagné
par les pouvoirs publics.
J'ai dit que nous aurions
l'accord
de la Commission
européenne
pour un déblocage
rapide des aides.
Hier,
nous avons effectivement
franchi un cap
technique crucial
sur les niveaux d'indemnisation.
Cela me permet
de vous confirmer
que le 20 février,
nous ouvrirons
des guichets d'aide
pour que les paiements puissent
arriver au début du mois de mars.
Ce dispositif vaut
pour les bateaux concernés,
mais un dispositif
spécifique
se crée
en collaboration
avec les élus locaux.
Je me rendrai
en fin de semaine
à la rencontre
de l'ensemble des acteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Loïc Prud'homme.
- Loïc Prud'homme: Merci.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
vous déclariez ici
avec assurance
il y a une semaine
à vouloir faire rimer
climat et croissance.
C'était votre dernière trouvaille.
Aujourd'hui,
le pétrolier va inaugurer
ce nouveau concept.
Il s'apprête à faire
de nouveaux forages
autour du bassin d'Arcachon.
Ce projet
est la définition parfaite
du mot "incohérence".
Madame Borne avait déclaré
en juillet dernier vouloir faire
de la France la première grande
nation industrielle
à s'émanciper
des énergies fossiles.
Vous regardez, passif,
la possible ouverture
de huit nouveaux puits de pétrole.
Vos arguments, je les connais.
"Mieux vaut
du pétrole local
que du pétrole importé."
C'est donc ça,
l'écologie à la française,
que vous nous vantiez
la semaine dernière?
Détruisons la biodiversité,
mais détruisons français.
Vous aurez ainsi
la fierté d'avoir dépassé
les dernières
limites planétaires
avec un désastre bleu-blanc-rouge.
Je vous le demande,
pour répondre
à l'urgence climatique,
aux citoyens
qui seront mobilisés
contre ce projet
dimanche prochain,
allez-vous faire
prévaloir la protection
de l'environnement
et la lutte
contre le changement
climatique
avant les intérêts financiers?
Allez-vous exiger
l'interdiction
de ces nouveaux forages
en pleine forêt?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
C'est dans ce pays,
dans cet hémicycle,
que le 30 décembre 2017,
l'Assemblée
nationale a décidé
pour la première
fois d'interdire
les nouveaux
forages pétroliers
et de dire qu'en
2040, en France,
il n'y aurait plus de forage
d'hydrocarbures.
A aucun moment,
la gauche,
dont vous vous réclamez,
n'avait utilisé
les mandats qu'elle avait eus
pour prendre
ce type de décisions.
La loi indiquait
qu'il y aurait
une enquête publique.
Elle s'est déroulée
au mois de septembre.
La décision
est désormais attendue.
Il faut parler de cohérence.
Il va falloir
que vous nous expliquiez
où est votre cohérence
quand il faut sortir
des énergies fossiles
et d'assumer
le fait que c'est par davantage
de nucléaire
que l'on va réussir à sortir
des énergies fossiles.
Vous êtes dans une position
qui consiste
à défendre à l'international
les dictateurs
qui proposent d'imposer
de nouveaux forages pétroliers
au Venezuela et au Guyana.
Vous reprochez
qu'en France,
dans le cadre
des lois existantes,
des dépôts de demandes
d'autorisation soient faits.
Vous dénoncez
l'inaction,
mais quand on vous propose
de voter
des dispositifs,
vous expliquez toujours
que c'est trop peu.
Soutenez la transition
écologique
à la française,
assumez la relance
du nucléaire!
Accompagnez-nous
sur les énergies renouvelables.
Sortez de votre confort
et de vos postures.
Il va être temps
que vous alliez forer
de nouvelles
idées
que celles que vous tentez
de nous recycler!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Nicolas Metzdorf.
- Nicolas Metzdorf: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Bruno
Le Maire.
La Calédonie repose
sur son nickel.
C'est 97%
de nos exportations,
13.000 emplois
directs et indirects,
qui représentent
20% des cotisations
qui vont à notre Sécurité sociale.
Malheureusement,
nous avons subi
ces derniers temps
la concurrence
des Chinois.
Ils ont massivement
investi en Indonésie
et mettent en péril nos usines.
Vous êtes venu
il y a quelques mois
nous présenter le pacte nickel.
C'est un accord
entre Calédoniens,
l'Etat et les multinationales
présentes.
Cela vise à améliorer
notre compétitivité
et sauver nos usines.
Malgré des efforts
à consentir,
les choses
sont plus compliquées
pour l'usine
du nord
que pour celle du sud.
C'est 1300
emplois directs
qui sont menacés de fermeture.
Monsieur le ministre,
nous devons faire
tous les efforts possibles
pour pouvoir sauver
ces emplois.
C'est une semaine décisive
qui s'est ouverte
à Paris.
Vous avez entamé
des discussions
avec la multinationale
présente et l'ensemble
des acteurs calédoniens.
Pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui indiquer
aux 250.000 Français
de Calédonie
qui nous regardent
quelles sont les évolutions
de ce dossier
et si nous allons parvenir
à ouvrir des perspectives
positives
pour l'industrie du nickel
en Nouvelle-Calédonie?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Je veux être très clair avec vous.
Nous croyons tous à l'avenir
de la filière nickel
en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Je me suis rendu
sur place
et nous avons visité
ensemble
les trois usines.
Il faut construire l'avenir
de la filière nickel
en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Il y a pour cela trois conditions.
Je les ai présentées
et répétées
à tous les élus.
La première,
c'est que l'ensemble
des élus s'engagent
sur le pacte nickel
avec un accord qui permettra
de mieux exploiter
la ressource minière
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
et d'en exporter
une partie
pour avoir de la trésorerie
supplémentaire
pour rendre nos usines
plus compétitives.
J'appelle tous
les élus à signer
ce projet d'accord.
La deuxième
condition,
c'est qu'il y ait
un soutien de l'Etat
pour moderniser
le réseau électrique
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Il faut avoir un prix
de l'énergie
qui soit moins élevé.
Le président
de la République et moi-même
avons pris des engagements.
Nous sommes prêts
à investir
dans le réseau énergétique
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
La troisième condition est claire.
Je la rappelle
ici: il faut
qu'il y ait des industriels.
Une usine
ne peut pas fonctionner
sans industriels.
L'Etat ne se substituera pas
aux industriels.
J'ai fait des propositions
pour l'usine
du nord.
Nous avons proposé 60
millions de subventions.
Nous avons proposé 45
millions d'euros
de ressources supplémentaires.
Tout cet argent vise
à garantir la pérennité
de l'usine du nord sous forme
de soutien public.
C'est maintenant
aux actionnaires
de prendre leurs responsabilités.
L'Etat a pris ses responsabilités.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur Metzdorf?
- Nicolas Metzdorf: Merci.
Je salue l'action du ministre.
Nous nous rendrons
dès demain sur place
pour continuer les discussions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance est suspendue.